it started out it was conservatives
pointing this out president trump
pointing this out now even mainstream
journalists are starting to bring it up
like this yahoo news guy and then joe
rogan the most prominent podcaster on
planet earth
no right winger by any means he was a
bernie bro during the primaries
joe rogan says it's pretty clear at this
point that biden is declining
and more importantly than that there's a
lot of voters in this country who maybe
they don't love trump maybe they're not
rock ribbed republicans maybe
maybe they don't have much of a
political view at all
they're just not comfortable with a guy
who can't pronounce
basic words or string together an
english sentence running
the most powerful office in the world i
believe there's an also
large group of people that are very
uncomfortable with a man who seems to be
mentally compromised
winning the election and doing so by
hiding
i mean the guys never he was just at
another thing the other day and he
forgot where he was
yeah and that happens all the time he
forgets where he is all the time and he
forgot his own name
i forgot the name of god and the
declaration of independence
he forgets a lot the democratic party
though is capitalizing on this they're
relying on this
it's it's not breaking news that joe
biden has lost a few steps
but what i think people are not fully
appreciating here
is that forgetfulness is the name of the
game this is how the democratic party
and the liberal establishment memory
whole stories that they just want you to
forget about they've been doing it for
decades right what they would do the
clintons were most famous for this
there would be a scandal and they would
deny deny deny
deny deny and then finally when they
couldn't deny it anymore they'd say well
that's old news
oh forget about that who cares and then
they'd bury it the media would bury it
you know nothing would be taught in
history books we just forget about these
things
that's what the the left has relied on
for a long time that's why
the left rewrites history is trying to
erase historical figures and in the case
of joe biden they're hiding him
in a basement right he's he is very
rarely leaving
his home every time he does any kind of
media hit
there's some complete embarrassment
where he's defending his own
his own cognitive strength by
contradicting himself from a couple
months ago and then not being able to
finish the phrase mental fitness so
they've got to hide him
joe biden's poll numbers right now if
you trust the polls
are pretty good they're good because
people don't remember
what and who joe biden is that's
something that the people have in common
with joe biden himself
they don't remember who this guy is
every time they see him
his numbers go down which is not a good
sign for a candidate
it means that as the race gets hotter if
there are debates
joe's numbers are going to continue to
decline now what the democrats are
banking on
is that joe's got such a lead right now
depending on which poll you look at he's
got a pretty substantial lead
that it will decline slow enough that
joe biden perhaps himself might decline
slow enough
to get him over the finish line for
november and they're trying to do
everything they can to preserve that by
keeping the country shut down
keeping the economy shut down canceling
the conventions and even trying to
cancel
the debates i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you